martine aubry annonce un possible
assouplissement de la loi veil sur les
vg l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse
la ministre de l'emploi et de la
solidarité envisage de la modifier mais
pas tout de suite
elle souhaite dans un premier temps agir
en amont une grande campagne en faveur
de la contraception va être lancé
christine numéro l'avortement parcours
du combattant pour encore beaucoup trop
de femmes 24 ans après la loi veil
martine aubry veut normaliser son
d'accès trop de blocages se sont
instaurés depuis des centres ivg parent
pauvre de l'hôpital des centres
d'orthogénie trop rares pour répondre
dans les temps à la demande
le milieu hospitalier va devoir faire un
effort nous allons demander aux hôpitaux
et notamment au service de gynécologie
obstétrique de mieux généraliser les
l'orthogénie en leur sein de mieux
accueillir les femmes de mieux les
accompagner et bref de traiter une
interruption volontaire de grossesse
dans sa complexité et dans sa globalité
et non pas comme un acte chirurgical
banal martine aubry suit ainsi les
recommandations du professeur nisand
menacé par des militants anti avortement
car il préconise de donner un nouveau
souffle à la loi mais martine aubry
laisse pour l'instant de côté deux de
ses propositions
libérés les mineurs de l'autorisation
parentale et allonger le délai de
recours à l'ivg et j je ne souhaite pas
que nous engagions une réforme de la loi
de 75 sans avoir préalablement réalisé
tout ce que nous pouvons faire pour que
en amont l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse ne soit que l'ultime recours
et que la contraception devient un mode
naturel et normal de traitement par la
femme
je dirais de sa sexualité de ses
conséquences une prudence pour ne pas
relancer un débat avec les anti ivg qui
ont réalisé des opérations commandos ces
dernières années tout d'abord faciliter
l'accès à la contraception d'urgence
avec la pilule du lendemain
maintenant en vente dans les pharmacies
et puis donner une très large
information sur la contraception avec
une campagne médiatique lancée à
l'automne
quelques pistes à suivre d'abord y
observer pendant un an avant de changer
la loi